foreign
people in southern Benin woke up to a
towel black smoke and a fire at a
Marketplace and seen kepaji the flames
and golf shops and houses in the area
Witnesses say gasoline was being
unloaded at a stone the explosion left
dozens of charred bodies at the site
it must be said that with the intensity
of the fire burn levels can sometimes
reach up to 100 of the affected body
surface that's how serious these cases
are
the
this fire burned all vehicles that had
lined up to stop fuel an investigation
is underway to determine the costs
many of the injured are in critical
condition
the cause of the fire was fuel
particularly Contraband fuel we also
recorded 20 injuries of varying severity
supplies brought in from its neighbor
Nigeria is a major oil producer and fuel
smuggling is common inside the country
and along its borders
illegal refineries fuel dumps and
pipelines have sprung up in towns like
these with little or no safety measures
to control fires
um Sharif Al Jazeera